so neues vom Sultan Erdogans Armee führt
Krieg gegen die Kurden in Syrien die
Region afrin war einer der wenigen die
weitgehend vom Bürgerkrieg verschont
geblieben ist und das durfte so
natürlich nicht bleiben fand der Erdogan
bei seiner sogenannten Operation
Olivenzweig sind schon mehrere Dutzend
Zivilisten ums Leben gekommen tausende
Menschen sind auf der Flucht unter
anderem müssen wir sagen auch vor
deutschen Panzern unser beliebtes
Premium-Modell der Leopard 2 da mit dem
Türken 354 Stück von vertickt die Kurden
von der sogenannten JPG wurden vor
kurzem noch als Helden gefeiert zurecht
für ein Kampf gegen den is wir haben zum
Beispiel die Jesiden gerettet und jetzt
guckt die ganze Welt einfach tatenlos zu
wie der Erdogan da einmarschiert auch
mit deutschen Panzern ich sag's noch mal
was sagt denn unser Außenministerium
zur Frage
der des Einsatzes von Leopard Panzern
mir
liegen keine Erkenntnisse also unser
bisheriges Lagebild gibt es nicht her
dass wir dass wir den Einsatz bestätigen
können
da müsste ich jetzt
habe hier nur die Brigitte zu legen
dieses Foto deinem Lagebild das neben
dem roten Pfeil ist ein Leopard die
übersieht man leicht die sind sehr klein
ja erdogan will mit aller Macht ein
autonomes Kurdengebiet an seiner Grenze
verhindern hatte man da fällt mir ein
haben wir den Kurden im Irak nicht
neulich noch unsere Milan Panzer
abwehrrakete geschenkt für mich hat es
dann sehr berührt als mir ein Vertreter
der Kurden im Nordirak erzählt hat dass
das Wort Milan jetzt ein Vorname für
Babys ist für männliche Babys weil die
so entzückt sind von den der Wirkung
dieses dieser Waffe oh wie süß hör mal
ist das süß
ja da können wir uns ja alle auf die
ersten türkischen Babys namens Leopard 1
und 2 freuen
ja
schön
entzückt sind von der Wirkung der Wache
dann heißt es Leo hör auf den Milan an
den Haaren zu ziehen ja das wäre doch
was deutsche Panzerabwehr gegen deutsche
Panzer das heißt Deutschland gewinnt in
jedem Fall weil wir und jetzt kommt's
allen liefern ja das ist so natürlich
ja wir wollen zwar die Guten sein aber
wir liefern an alle Freunde zwar dieser
Mann Sigmar Gabriel immer behauptet er
würde das mit den Rüstungsgeschäften
viel restriktiver handhaben als seine
Vorgänger aber das ist wie sich diese
Woche rausgestellt hat nicht ganz
richtig rechnet man den Umfang der
deutschen Rüstungsexporte zusammen zeigt
sich noch nie hat eine Bundesregierung
so viele Exporte genehmigt wie die noch
amtierende große Koalition yes 25
Milliarden durch Rüstungsexporte das
sind 20% mehr als die pazifistischen
Looser von Schwarz-Gelb
kein Wunder das rüstungsaktien durch die
Decke gehen allein der Kurs vom
leopardausrüster reinmetall ist im
letzten Jahr um unfassbare 70% gestiegen